he tubers is Charlie so everybody is
making a whole bunch of noise about
Squirrel Girl in the Marvel movies she's
kind of like the spider-man
Deadpool character which is why I don't
think that she's gonna make it into the
movies they already have spider-man to
be that and Fox has Deadpool so here's
just a quick explainer for the character
and why people want her in Avengers
infinity war so bad so I thought it'd be
fun to do a couple comic book videos
today everyone has been going crazy
about Anna Kendrick playing Squirrel
Girl in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and while I don't think that that is
gonna happen anytime soon I'm just gonna
explain why everyone's going so crazy
about it and why all of sudden right now
people are going nuts you know rim shot
off in the background if you're not
familiar with Squirrel Girl she debuted
in the early 90s not too long after
Deadpool debuted just as kind of like
this light-hearted happy comic-book
character her only real powers are the
ability to understand squirrels she can
just understand what squirrels are
saying in the way that Han Solo can
understand what Chewbacca is saying she
has sharp claws that allow her to climb
really easily she has knuckle spikes
that are retractable she has a tail and
she basically resembles a squirrel with
the powers of a normal squirrel
so like Galactus says here like in the
grand scheme of things when she's
talking to these other big cosmic beings
the powers of a squirrel not that big a
deal the way she's used in the comics is
the big deal she's kind of like the new
Deadpool in the more modern comics now
she's been around since 1992 so even now
the character Deadpool is used
differently in the comics like the tone
of Deadpool is a little bit different
the way he's written a little more
family-friendly than he was when he
first debuted but at their core like the
difference between Deadpool and Squirrel
Girl you know aside from their powers
and the actual stuff that they're doing
is what their characters represent so
Deadpool is kind of like the character
used to comment on comic book things in
general like there's this really funny
panel from the recent dead issue where
he's making fun of Batman V Superman I
don't get it this is just absolutely
crazy why would they be finding each
other
Squirrel Girl is also like a really meta
character but she's also used to
highlight the Wonder and joy of comic
books but she's this infinitely
renewable source of positivity and
excitement the soul of adventure like oh
my god which of these New Avengers is
going to be my best friend and she's
actually part of one of the Avengers
teams now she's part of the aim Avengers
team you have to remember right now in
Marvel Comics things are a little bit
crazy there are three different Avengers
teams but that's basically like the sign
that the character wears around like all
of this is amazing let's just go have
some fun like look at this panel right
here Squirrel Girl add a Marvel
convention with Howard the Duck it looks
like she drugged him along with her and
made him dress up as Squirrel Girl and
she dressed up as Howard the Duck so
they're cosplaying as each other
although it doesn't look like Howard the
Duck did this willingly this is kind of
what the character represents like this
is all just a little bit silly but it's
so much fun so now that in the movies
were in phase 3 we're moving to phase 4
we're gonna have Avengers infinity war
it's gonna be so crazy with like you
know sixty plus characters that the
Russo brothers are teasing
we have fan o's with the Infinity
Gauntlet the biggest reasons people are
talking about Squirrel Girl or because
well you have all these characters so
naturally there's an opportunity to slip
her in is just like a fun Easter Egg the
people are like Anna Kendrick already
kind of plays Squirrel Girl tight
characters in the movies that she stars
in and she looks a little bit like the
character like this is some boss logic
fan art and aside from just like you
know a few teeth enhancements she pretty
much looks like the character but the
reason I think we're not gonna see her
in the movies anytime soon is because
she's just like a little too much like
we have the spider-man character in the
Marvel movies he's kind of filling that
role of the character who's new to it
all and just views it all with this
great sense of wonder like oh my god
being a superhero is amazing this is
just the greatest thing that's ever
happened to me so you just have this
great sense of excitement from the
character and that's kind of what
Squirrel Girl does so you don't really
need another character to do that she
really works best
inside the comics she is like peak comic
book like this Howard the Duck panel is
the most comic book thing that you will
ever see in a Marvel comic book like I
will argue that she has become more a
comic book than Deadpool because this
comic book panel here is heard a comic
book convention Deadpool is talking more
about movie things he's kind of
transcended into the realm of comic book
movies which are comic book related but
they're a little more mainstream so I
will say yella there's totally a chance
we could see the Squirrel Girl character
in the movies it's just that it would be
the animated movies they would be much
more appropriate for the tone of her
character like she has her own version
of the Thanos copter like
never gonna see the Thanos copter in the
movies it's just is just too much so let
me know in the comments like what is the
most obscure funny character that you
would want to see in the movies that you
would never think that they'd be able to
do like MODOK would be funny like they
just made Donald Trump MODOK in the
gwenpool comic book that would be
absolutely ridiculous but hopefully that
explains like why people are going crazy
about Anna Kendrick Squirrel Girl right
now it's just that the actress was like
yeah you know of course I would love to
be in a Marvel movie everyone who is a
human being would like to be in a Marvel
movie even Donald Trump the fact that
they made him a comic book villain he
would probably want to be in a Marvel
movie if given the chance that is the
thing that will never happen that I
totally want to see in a Marvel movie so
let me know in the comments like what is
the thing that they will never do the
character they'll never do that you want
to see them do in the Marvel movies so
in related comic book news in the spirit
of holiday fun I'm gonna do a Deadpool
video next so that should post later
tonight be sure to subscribe to get it
if there are any other comic book videos
that you guys want me to do this week
you know for the movies TV shows or just
the comic books themselves just let me
know in the comments there'll be a lot
of Marvel and DC stuff happening we have
DC rebirth we have Marvel's Civil War
then the flash season 3 actually starts
rolling camera shooting footage this
week so there'll be a whole bunch of
stuff to talk about this week so why you
guys wait for me to post that Deadpool
video you can click here to watch
Deadpool troll x-men apocalypse that's
right they got Ryan Reynolds to troll
that movie and you can click here for
all my DC rebirth flash videos thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you